this is your Tech news briefing for
Wednesday April 5th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
when you interact with digital
assistants like Alexa and Siri you
probably imagine a female responding to
your requests that's because the
designers of these programs have
assigned them traditionally female
sounding names and voices they aren't
the first digital tools to be given
genders think fictional robots like
Rosie on The Jetsons or the Terminator
but is it a bad idea to give these
devices traditionally male or female
names voices even appearances
some experts have expressed concerns but
Recent research suggests there may be at
least one big reason to give technology
a gender
with me to discuss this is Chris
cornelis who wrote about this topic for
the wsj's journal reports hi Chris
thanks for joining me good to be here
Zoe thanks Chris let's start with the
concerns why do some experts say it's
not a good idea to give robots or other
digital assistants genders the idea is
any time that a gender is associated
with a piece of technology that all of
the stereotypes that come with that
gender are going to be associated with
it and it's going to reinforce those
ideas and a really common one they point
to is Siri and Alexa these digital
assistants were given a female names and
they've been accused of being very
submissive and willing to take criticism
the concern is that it reinforces some
of these negative stereotypes okay but
there is a possible good reason to give
machines a gender according to this new
paper can you tell us what the
conclusions of that were this paper
looks at what happens when technology
what a robot when artificial
intelligence is given a gender and what
they're finding is people find those
things to be more human-like and when
people find technology to be more
human-like they grow more attached well
if tech companies want people to be
attached to their technology they want
that to happen it doesn't seem all that
surprising I feel like I've always given
my cars names and that's not such an
unusual thing and ships and guitars it's
very common think about Tom Hanks and
Castaway giving the volleyball a gender
I mean it's very common for people to do
that and this researchers I spoke to
said too gender is very closely tied to
humanness the question though from the
researcher is is there an upside to
having people be attached to their
technology Beyond selling more products
tell me a little bit more about the
studies that were used for this paper
and who was doing the research the
researcher Stanford was the lead author
of this paper and she and her colleagues
they looked at how do people rate their
autonomous vacuum cleaners for example
and what they found was they found
people who are humanizing their robotic
vacuums they're finding them to get
higher ratings and have a closer
attachment to them is there any
indication that companies are
considering this issue when they're
thinking about putting out a new product
or naming a product
the researchers I spoke to said these
companies don't do things by accident
they know what they're doing are they
giving it a female gender to be
malicious that is not the implication
here but the idea is that they know what
they're doing and they're saying too not
all of the stereotypes are negative the
female stereotype of being kind and
being somebody who's affectionate these
are positive things that we want from
people from humans but one of the things
that they're saying is they're not
giving the technology with power the
female identity not as many female
Terminators I guess that's right that's
right so is there a way to avoid some of
the downsides of the stereotypes
according to the researchers you spoke
to that remains an open question and
what they were looking at is this
reinforcing stereotypes period and
parsing out how do you do this without
you reinforcing negative stereotypes
that would say takes more study and
really is almost a more complicated
issue so does that mean everything from
like my laptop to the microphone that
I'm talking to you through like are all
of them going to have genders there's
enough room in my life to be attached to
my lamp and my pen and my laptop but
we've seen the attempts everywhere as
you've said to give names and genders to
things I think there's probably no end
to the attempt to do this not as many
will stick Chris cornelis thanks for
joining us thanks for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]